hey youtubers is Charlie best news ever
josh brolin is cast as cable that's
right Thanos is going to be cable in the
Fox movies I know that just blows your
mind so I'll explain what's going on
with infinity war if you're new to the
channel I do Marvel and DC every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
know a lot of you are confused about how
shano's can be in the Fox movies because
he's doing both infinity war films they
haven't confirmed a lot for that second
one but they're filming them
back-to-back Santos will always be a big
character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so there's a lot of trickery
going on behind the scenes and I can
explain what some of those four movies
are Josh Brolin's Deadpool contract are
going to be and if you were confused by
some of the things in this teaser that
Ryan Reynolds dropped obviously Josh
Brolin faces in the copy they're just a
nod to cable they're the dominoes
sitting over here just a reference to za
z beats being Domino but then this is
for the Golden Girls here these are all
the Golden Girls
Deadpool is a long-running thing in the
comics where he's this big Bea Arthur
Golden Girls fan so they worked that
into the first movie they had Betty
White record this funny trailer
dissipated movie of the year
Deadpool it was glorious once in a
generation a movie comes along that your
whole family will love if your family is
a hood up group of giving him bread Plus
Ryan Reynolds look so kin handsome in
his religion I give it for Golden Girls
it's the best picture of the year and
then in the actual movie because Ryan
Reynolds in real life is also a Bea
Arthur fan in addition to the Deadpool
character he contacted Bea Arthur's son
got permission to put her face on his
t-shirt so when Wade Wilson is walking
around in the first part of the film
before he becomes Deadpool he's wearing
a t-shirt with Bea Arthur's face on it
so just a whole bunch of golden girls
funny stuff going on behind the scenes
expect them to do the same thing when
the second movie comes out too so
there's a lot of stuff to explain let's
start with the basic Deadpool news so
Josh Brolin is going to be playing
Nathan summers cable in Deadpool 2 first
there's going to be a Deadpool 3 they've
already started talking about it there's
going to be an x-force movie so when
they say you sign for four movies that's
what those three
are the fourth one could be anything it
could be Deadpool four it could be
x-force two it's more likely it would be
x-force two or some other x-men universe
film but the important thing to remember
is they've already confirmed a lot about
the future of the Deadpool side of the
x-men universe mostly the next force
will spin out directly from the Deadpool
sequels both Deadpool and cable will be
main characters in the x-force movie so
they're getting ready to ramp up on
pre-production on Deadpool 2 they're
finishing the script they've already
found most of their characters they have
their dominoes Ozzy beats it's going to
be crazy it's never going to be exactly
like the comics the first Deadpool movie
changed a whole bunch of stuff about his
backstory and the characters they use
but most of the Deadpool one characters
will be returning for Deadpool two that
includes negasonic teenage warhead
Colossus will probably come back to the
big takeaway is that most of the
characters are coming back there'll be a
bunch more obscure characters that will
pop up in x-force if you've read the
comic you know it's more like an r-rated
version of an x-men movie so it'll be a
little easier to predict what they're
going to do with that once we see
Deadpool - we've already got a version
of that teaser there were a bunch of
Easter eggs for a cable even Hope
Summers even though I don't think that
Hope Summers is going to be a part of
the Deadpool sequels I'll link that at
the end of this but the next big
question you all have is what about the
Marvel side of things what does this say
about Josh Brolin's role as Thanos in
the infinity war films and the rest of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the most
likely thing is that Fox and Marvel came
to an arrangement where they allowed him
to do this because his Thanos
performance is 100% motion capture
you wouldn't know was Josh Brolin if he
didn't recognize his voice so with a lot
easier for him to go off and do other
movies without casual moviegoers getting
completely confused so you and me we're
big comic book fans will definitely
recognize the fact that it's Josh Brolin
oh my god Thanos is cable and Deadpool's
make it all the goonies jokes but on the
flip side a lot of people are like does
this mean that they're going to recast
Thanos in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is always possible but I don't think
they're going to do that Marvel wants
nothing more than to find a spider-man
Sony style sharing arrangement with the
Fox characters everybody keeps asking or
they're going to be fantastic for things
happening
at Thor Ragnarok because this Jack Kirby
comic book panel with the Fantastic Four
in it looks exactly like what's
happening in Thor Ragnarok now that's
really just Jack Kirby stuff that's
going on there it's not necessarily
Fantastic Four stuff but they're going
to be so many conspiracy theorists now
that say oh if they let Foxx use Josh
Brolin does that mean that they get to
use Fantastic Four stuff it's always
possible but I don't think that's the
case I think they just came to the
arrangement that they can use Josh
Brolin because he's only motion capture
so it's probably just a matter of
scheduling and financial stuff going on
because Thanos is going to be a really
big part of the first infinity war film
we don't know exactly what's happening
in the second part other than it will
just be addressing the consequences of
what Thanos does when he assembles the
Infinity Gauntlet the Avengers trying to
fix the universe but they said the
second one isn't even going to be called
infinity wars because it's going to be
so different from the first film so it's
possible that Thanos is not as big in
the second film and that's why he has
that much more time later this year to
film the Deadpool movie because it takes
a long time to film a movie way longer
than a couple weeks so he's going to
have to be walking around with Ryan
Reynolds this whole time so one of the
benefits of them filming both infinity
war films back-to-back at Marvel over in
Atlanta is that actors are coming and
going throughout the year Chris Evans
just said that he's getting ready to go
film his infinity war scenes but like
Robert Downey jr. the other actors are
going at different times during the year
because they're not all going to be on
screen at the same time and because he's
only doing motion capture it's a lot
easier for Josh Brolin to shoot his
scenes he can walk around with one of
the suits with the dots on it but they
can also have a double on set if they
wanted to Rocket Raccoon style and have
him just do the voice later the way that
Bradley Cooper does that but James
Gunn's brother actually plays Rocket
Raccoon when they're filming on set so
there's just a number of ways to explain
how Josh Brolin can spend all this time
later this year filming Deadpool 2 while
at the same time working on infinity war
stuff far and away this is the easiest
slam dunk for them he has the presence
besides the physical size to be
intimidating next to Ryan Reynolds
because Ryan Reynolds is super tall
already so anyone you would cast as
cable
even though there will be a little bit
of CG has to be a huge person who has
the presence to overpower him demeanor
is that of a pouty child and apparently
Whaley invaded my Stanford daughter
shall honor our agreement
Cree if returned to me again at the end
they stall ways in your blood they need
to be someone who can do comedy because
he has to work with Deadpool so it's
this really weird puzzle piece they have
to fit like Michael Shannon was a really
solid pick but I don't know what his
comedic timing would have been like next
to Ryan Reynolds and a lot of people
behind the scenes are saying that he was
hesitant to commit to a for picture deal
but Josh Brolin is totally into comic
book movies he was so excited when he
got to beef a nose the first time
remember way back during comic-con 2015
when he came out with the Infinity
Gauntlet on he was having so much fun so
he is totally down to hang out with Ryan
Reynolds for four more movies a lot of
you were asking about the story was it
going to be they will be true to the
original first meeting of cable and
Deadpool in the comics they were
definitely not friends Deadpool was
hired to kill cable for Tolliver while
cable was putting a team together to
fight strife back in the future so
they're going to be white elements that
they don't do from the comic book I'm
not expecting strife stuff to be
happening I'm not expecting them to do
any apocalypse stuff because stripes is
connected to apocalypse in the comics so
just expect there to be a lot of changes
in expect them to butt heads in the most
fun way possible when they first meet
but that's part of their chemistry is
that they hate each other but they work
so well together so cable cannot stand
Deadpool but they are both so good at
what they do that they have to come
together and then you throw Domino in
the mix and she's been both an
antagonist in a friend to both cable and
Deadpool in the comics so the
relationship between all three of them
is just going to be nuts it'll be a lot
of fun but if you want to read up on
their original first meeting cable
debuted in the comics in New Mutants
number 87 now he debuted as a baby
way before then an uncanny x-men but he
want to start with him as cable the
first time he saw Deadpool was many many
issues later in New Mutants number 90
so you could read those two issues like
first appearance of cable then first
appearance of Deadpool then you can read
x-force number one just to get some
background on exports but we're still a
long ways away from that movie happening
if you're not reading any Deadpool
comics right now you can start with
mercs for money Domino's taken over the
team but there are a billion Deadpool
comics out there so just find something
you like and check it out don't worry
you don't have to read all the comics to
understand what's going on that's kind
of what my channel exists for so I'll
point out all the Easter eggs as they
start to announce more stuff but the
fact that are announcing their cable now
one because there's so much comic-book
stuff happening this week with Star Wars
Celebration DC just dropped all that
Justice League footage Marvel dropped
its thor ragnarok trailer so it's just
like everybody dumping their really cool
news this week so it's just like the
best thing ever I'll leave all your
requests for Deadpool bonus videos in
the comments below what's going to
happen next is is there's a flash
trailer that I want to get out and then
it's going to be all Star Wars mostly
for the rest of the week just a whole
bunch of really cool stuff there'll be
new Star Wars the last Jedi trailer so
just leave all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments what you wait for
that you can click here to rewatch that
Deadpool 2 trailer video and you can
click here for brand new Star Wars thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you